feel like busting luke feel like busting
liz
yeah hi evelyn
hi jasper welcome back
that's so nice to see you again no no i
found you on the street yet again
ah it's a beautiful day in san francisco
in the tenderloin
yes it is
one time i was in a rest home and my
family
left me and as i entered the restaurant
a ball of flame came behind the glass
doors
and i said no socks no service
and my birthday was the next day so i
went back to the rest home
and my family pulled in
and we went for a waterfall walk
so i saw a girl in a bikini
and i
think it was my brother-in-law
or maybe even knew that me as you're
looking towards me
said nice tan
and a bear climbed in the water
and took a towel and strangled the goat
by putting it on its horns
so i said heidi ho
and my family wouldn't let me back in
the car because
i had used the word hope and my brother
yells out the window
she's not a prostitute
and the way he said it and the way i
took it were 200 years apart
so my mom takes the roll of toilet paper
and sticks it out the window
and it rolls around the antenna
and they have a 10 pound block of cheese
on the hood of the car
and as they're going down the road sure
enough
the front end of the car is lifted
and they ram into a motor home
which my sister had rented to towel
often
evelyn can i ask you a question yes tell
me about the great loves of your life
oh travel no i mean i mean like the
dad maybe the people in your life the
men fresh fruit
what about the men have you been in love
before no i never have
never no i never have you were married
i've been
active you were married yeah i was
married to shakespeare for seven years
and how was that
he wears leather
his voice went out
evelyn what are you proudest of in your
life
finishing college it's good for you
yeah where'd you go to school manhattan
princeton for piano
yale for running hunter for science
and i saw einstein and i was reading a
book
and it took me a long time to get a
brain that would stay captive i was in
love with
indian lore that's all i had
i had been a young girl and i was
very uh petite
in the muscle area that gets stretched
so i didn't know it but they signed me
up for olympic training
and i came out and the child pushed me
from
behind and i took his head and i didn't
know i was so strong
that my mother was born in 1940
and he started crying
and i said i'm not going to juni said
do something so i got my
my finger out
and i threw a bottle and it hit a boy
in the eye and a teacher came over and
said
we're gonna make a tortoise chamber for
you
little girl you apologize
i said i repent and i went to the front
of the school
i said torture
so i was on a river walk he just had
monopoly money
and he wanted me he said why am i
queer today and a bus went behind him
and it stopped and it didn't it didn't
um honk its horn and i said
um why don't we go get a square fruit
cake
and he said oh you mean that sugarless
gum
and i bend over and he disappears behind
the gate and boards the bus
and waves to me from the window it's
pulled down about an
end i go bye bye baby he goes
you're too skinny for sugarless gum i
thought that was pretty good for
monopoly money on the riverwalk
your teeth skinny if it's sugarless gum
they knew his way
turned out to be a fire department's
plug
one of the fire department had ripped
his eyelid on a tree
coming down to the cadillac market i
left them an inkjet printer but we
didn't have any toner
so i turned myself in for
child abuse because i left a baby
in a safety section on death row
this was when land was very small we
just
had a walk through a concrete block it
was freezing cold
there was even rain dripping from the
ceiling people lying to the side
cuts on their eyebrows their their
fingers and whole arm displayed on
concrete
one arm was stepped on and yelped and
closed his eye
and i bent over to awaken him
and to sue them and bring him
a block of reality
and they cuffed me and used their
nightsticks they
even put it up to the sleeve of my slabs
so when they did that i didn't object
and immediately i was on the sandhill
day platform
seeing the train come in and i bent over
to look at it and the conductor grabbed
me by the back of the collar
and he said why don't you go get some
matches and i went
around thinking that i was in
the subway and i wound up in front of
burger king
and a man was taking hit after hit off a
pipe striking math after match
i said that made 16 and the cops walked
up behind me
i said you aren't a cop until you've
seen this
man making food disorientation
and they went in and they said this
place doesn't have a food license
and they closed them that night and i
said
well um i prefer not to starve to death
if you could walk me over to the fire
department and it took us
five hours and 14 minutes and i said um
i'm gonna sit down there and
the concrete was soaking wet and they
caught
came over to me and they were naked
except for
underpants i said why don't we go down
to the park and we did
and they pulled out a beauty kit they
filed my nails
told me why it wasn't necessary to flesh
the toilet
that the wells were 35 feet deep
and that they were national geographic
photographers
that they had seen me in alaska dipping
my hands into acid
to save her raincoat my sister had slept
in weight
she had opened an ammonia tank with a
key
and she denied it but when i threw an
orange into a box to make a boyfriend
for myself
the nba coach walked up behind me he
said um
the doc's ready with popeye fish
and he fell in and his chin was hanging
from the dock
and i said i'll marry you if you show me
my two fingers
and i almost fell in but i was trembling
from behind i said
evelyn when he gets up you can walk to
any job site you want and i did i got a
job that day
in an alaskan bar called uh
pete's pete's whistle stop cafe
and i met sally rand she circled the
earth with monkeys
she landed in the florida keys
and i also met chet eisenhower
hydroplane driver
he drives on water and
bonnie lake and bonnie riot
were also in the bar and they walked me
through a concrete uh block
of non-tenements you know where the army
uh the barracks they walked me through
the barracks
of 1939 when hitler
surrendered to the japanese and and
paris and he didn't speak french
and when he stopped talking
russia did what russia was made
they only speak to people who look 17
it doesn't matter if you tell them
they're asian just go huh
you go back to work
so evelyn what were you your high school
years like what kind of teenager were
you
i was a smelly cat people
said i had body odor i was very nervous
i wanted to be a cook
very bad but i just had a halter top it
was real cute
my first day of high school my sister
had been
nearly killed being thrown out of a car
but i learned three days later that she
didn't know the word road
but i spread the word that day i said
we've got to be careful about
these cars and everybody says oh yeah
we can't go to high school so we all got
the giggles and we ran out we became
cheerleaders that day in
short uniforms i was the only one
dressed in black
they said evelyn get up and show us what
you can do
and i said oh i'm not tanana
they said oh you know what eddie mark is
riding up through the mountains today
and i ran home i said i've got to be all
alone so i can write where i want to be
when i turn into olympians
and my dad says remember when we had
pizza he says i've got another big one
for you
and my brother walked in
with a christmas tree and he said i just
bought a
is house potato salad ready
and he said i'm so glad you're home
evelyn and he
handed me a money order and he said um
dad
bought a golf set with his um nrc money
i said the nicholaret i said the fda
warns you that this is a jurisdiction
and he left the house screaming and
crying and he said
god she's a cop i thought she was a u.s
marine and he sticks his tongue out the
window
and my mom comes over and she had a
rifle
and i said man that's her leg
that's what i learned in the marines
that your hips if you keep going like
this
eventually you'll make a gun because
your
your legs will collect fat and you'll
keep talking
or the window will bust and so he drove
out in his vw
and he came back four hours later he
said
evelyn i want to marry you i'm gonna do
it or give me that money order back
so i got in the back seat of the
volkswagen
and i was really
decided that i had to live
as a waitress and i said jim can you
drive me up the road
and drop me off and i
checked out a video and there was a
woman lying like this and i was
attracted to the dress
and i brought the video tape home and it
was of a girl walking behind
a theme and suddenly the
the tape turned into the uss missouri
with people dancing on it and so now i
was in the cadillac hotel
or the um uh the sunnyside hotel it's a
it's a boy's year's home it turned into
that when they
finally got the manager to stop giving
away bribes
he would tell people to go get coffee
for him he was
uh on the verge of near collapse from
food poisoning
because the pizza was the only thing
that san francisco had not even
drink to follow it so i didn't have any
umbrella and i was pushing and pushing
my pipe
so this morning i was woken up with a
thrust
that's a fight that you don't win to
make the thresh
you're not liking people you don't want
to wake up
and i heard a boy say go ahead and get
up
they're going to belt you in and soon
enough sam took the belt off i'd stuck
it under a disco
dance garage somebody looped a belt
around my neck trying to murder me
i never found out who they were
but i had come down from
hotel with a cup of coffee he had asked
me not to take it
and as i went out the door with the
coffee cup
sure enough somebody bam
a leather belt around my neck and they
hooked it to when they
closed the door they there was no screen
on there
so as my first check it was just six
dollars
i got the whole six dollars they didn't
know to enumerate the bank and the
couriers
you know these banks will be stocked
with young people
eating vegetable pie and and uh
nibbling on old day old pizza
yeah what's your favorite childhood
memory
oh finding the side of that house open
when i could peek through a house
or seeing a minced cat full fur
that was the most fur i've ever
descended there was a man below the
the well that well was 15 feet deep
he had been in there for five days
somebody had moaned a back lawn and
built a house with lumber
this was back when there was free land
and i had stepped on a nail when i was
young so i was put on life support
in in beth israel hospital they had
flown me by helicopter this was the year
before the
vietnam war ended so i guess they
wouldn't let communism go to
go anywhere near even americans they
feared the word
and i said would you rather be a racist
and i started up my bike
and i rode for 13 hours and i stopped on
the railroad tracks
and sure enough a train went by two
two two and i walked through it my mom
was on the other side
so was my little sister her zipper had
been zipped up to her chin
she had also been taken to a hospital
but she had been like that for seven
hours
just cuddling her throat and when they
unzipped it boy did she cry
she was trembling she's still a very
shaky girl
but she doesn't talk much she fears the
human voice but
she's friends with brook shields
i had met her on the bus she had a
band-aid on her knee and we
both got our our photograph taken by
uh richard dreyfuss and a gang member
julia dreyfuss got off she overeats
of cream so i met her as a waitress and
she
put a plate down on a on a
she's a waitress to a food server but
she is a glutton whereas i am a
old fart with gassy legs but anyway my
hamstrings are short so i can
stretch and jump and i said five inches
will get you a mile
and sure enough she kicks the king in
the hip
i said he is the king for getting
through your
abusive mother syndrome i said you don't
have to be a mother
she said i used to grow pot but they
busted me in the old folks home
i said evelyn that's so funny and they
served me
a watermelon juice and
i guess his hip was against the bar
stool because
when he sat up there was a hamburger
and a fried mushroom and that was all my
dinner for seven days
as i dated carlos carlos my
father-in-law
his son is a welder up in portland he
also grows wheat
and mary picks cotton she was with me
it was just the two of us uh rep butler
in savannah georgia
evelyn yeah who's your favorite beatle
paul mccartney paul mccartney because he
does photography he's married to linda
she doesn't have a last name she's
famous too in in music circles she's
very light-skinned
so you can't see her unless you're you
know sensitive but security guards
she she likes to read too she also
paints in oils
she was born in a matisse painting i was
at the gutenberg
museum my first afternoon in new york
knowing i had to college
and i was yelling down the street i said
that isn't your voice and i said may i
join you and i cross the street
and a girl punched me in my face and
broke my jaw
and so i said what should i do i
said ellen you're a marine you you've
got information
growing through your arms i said you
need some seeds
so i found a pomegranate and i ate half
of it and i fell just by it was
sparkling
and i met a uh endorsement that's
somebody with us
you're in a big city with a big career
an endorphin
anyway he was a clown and so he tried to
teach me to juggle
and i spent five days on the
chappaquiddit
hall the land was very small
it was about two inches long that was
the first land when i ate that
pomegranate before that
people had to walk on water sit in beds
and so anyway this man had been
underground for five days and when i got
up i saw his rib cage
he was naked and didn't have any sperm
count
and so i stuck my finger up his bullbag
and that became the king's abusive
mother
so she's a queer i watch her eyes i find
her friends i tell you is the king is
out of your thoughts
but uh you know he is sensitive being
slapped in the head six times but
you know she was underground for five
days
so he may never know that being is
she did hit him five times in in the
stool channel
red red wine
stay close to me this time
i don't want to be on the line
i'm blessed in my hands
i got the blues
red red white makes me feel so fine red
while you make me feel so fine i'm on
the vine
all the time you got
the blues
okay i love it when you sing thank you
yeah i did major in theater that's why i
moved to new york
my father's from rochester the hudson
river descends into that town
i walked there on a field walk to get my
license to teach
and sure enough as i did that i was in
the
dulles airport it was just four feet
long
and i ran i ran and i busted my
breasts on the door and i stood there
and i said stop trembling this mall has
got to be made
and i went like this i remember
kennewick in canada
soon enough there was a mall and i went
shopping there with the ten dollars the
king had given me for
sharing my watermelon juice with him
he still doesn't eat meat he drinks beer
fresh water yeah he's the only black man
i know who likes water
and barbarian he coats me out of the
half a pound of cocaine this morning
he sucks on it a lot of people do too
cocaine
i smoke it on the pipe because i just
have
because i i just do not have a
icy appearance i don't like that but i
am from a cold climate
but i was invited to hawaii
because they needed a receptionist for a
bordello
they i knew what sex was since the time
i was two
i had my eyes wide open but i just had a
one and three-quarter glance
but they gave me all the cigarette i
wanted me
they were so well-landed but we were
rich in sugar
because uh that was when slave ships
were rolling and gasoline was free
you could grab candy bars and but my
favorite was
jim dandy to the rescue my father bought
halloween candy with his
he signed up to be a judge before that
he was unemployed on the verge of
hysterical breakdown
he slept in high stack when he was seven
years old
and had the wand of the land landing up
as a
female with a dress on he he preaches
one of his sons and i guess you can call
his right-wing man my brother jerry my
mom's
brother had a son and she adopted him in
court papers when
my sister was married and came home from
reno
she went to school in arizona along with
jim bishop
yeah season accountant for the irs
see that's tax filing
evelyn are you good for today you want
to take a break yeah sure
that was fun okay thank you i love
hearing you sing thanks can we get back
in the car now
absolutely okay thank you sure
you got the blues
breads red while you make me feel so
fine i'm on the blind most all of the
time
i love your singing thank you